i've reacted to a bunch of try guys
medical videos and now they're about to
see who's gonna live the longest biwoo
i don't know how long i'm gonna live
that's normal i think i'm a little
afraid
to know that's normal my biggest hurdle
is that i love food and flavors come
from fat and salt and sugar and all
these things that are bad for you and i
would be unpleasantly surprised to find
out that some of my life habits before
are unfixable our lifestyle habits most
definitely contribute to the longevity
of our lives but something that is less
often considered the quality of our
lives what if i was to tell you one of
your habits will only show in your life
by maybe five years you're gonna live to
100 now 95 but the 30 years before that
you're gonna have to be on oxygen you
won't be able to breathe well you won't
be able to run around with your kids and
grandchildren
that's an important factor isn't it a
couple weeks ago we sent in this color
kit with a sample of our saliva to find
out about our genetic disposition and
any sort of health
issues we might be needing to watch out
for we analyze uh 60 different genes 30
cancer 30 heart health genes it really
just gives you kind of a more tailored
look at your cancer and your heart
health
i'm gonna say it outright so that you
understand where my biases lie going
into this video i think these types of
tests are largely useless not saying
genetic tests are largely useless
because there's absolutely a role for it
we actually have geneticists that work
in hospitals that help with genetic
planning if you have a genetic condition
that you want to make sure that if
you're having children it won't be
passed down or if it will be what are
the percentages etc but the ones that
like are commercially available to tell
you how long you live not only are they
terribly inaccurate because they can't
possibly take in all the variants that
can go on in one's life they also don't
test for everything and at times can
give you a false sense of security that
ultimately ends up worsening your
behaviors
so i took the color test so you know
everything about me now so we
do i have chlamydia color does not test
for that oh that was a different test
okay so we analyzed 30 different genes
related to things like hereditary high
cholesterol
and different heart diseases and we
didn't find any mutations
that's uh a relief important important
important point commercial genetic tests
do not test for all the types of
variants for
a lot of these conditions so i don't
want people to do these tests thinking
that they're all good and remember not
all cancers are genetic many of them
develop spontaneously some as a result
of lifestyle habits like binging alcohol
or overeating fried or fatty foods if
i'm not predisposed to having
cholesterol issues i don't have to worry
about eating a ton of fried chicken like
i already you do though see like that's
what we want to avoid so i'm great my
genes could not be better that's right
wow so i get cancer
my genes cannot be better she goes
that's right
it's what you pay this for so that
doesn't guarantee that you won't get
cancer in the future or that you don't
have an increased risk based on other
genes or other non-genetic factors
there's the legal stuff or how about
saying the fact that you may still have
cancer right now that would have been
that would have killed the vibe of the
video we did find one mutation in a gene
called brca1 or some people call it
braco braca yeah i know about broncho
is that something that's
been tested for in your family or how
did you know about it so my mother
had breast cancer and it was discovered
she had the brocco one gene i know that
it's very common in ashkenazi jews and
that if you have it there's a 50 chance
of you passing it down to your children
um
i put off getting the test because i'm
like i don't want to know also if you
have a broncho1 gene mutation there has
been a correlation with more aggressive
prostate cancer if you do develop
prostate cancer bracha 2 has been more
correlated with actually development of
prostate cancer i know that it affects
women a lot more seriously than men
and luckily
my sister and the other women in my
family all tested negative for it which
is relieving but so
so i have it
so what does that mean having that gene
increases your likelihood of getting
breast cancer not a guarantee something
like knowing that i have the bracha gene
can be really scary but instead i'm
going to look at the positive you know
knowledge is power there's a lot you can
do to prevent it reducing your risk of
cancer oftentimes it's reducing your
alcohol intake eating healthy fresh
foods is really important and then
exercise is really really key in cancer
reductions isn't it interesting how the
advice for whether you're talking about
reducing prostate cancer losing weight
decreasing cardiac risk is all the same
exercise eat lots of fruits and
vegetables and meats in moderation sleep
well mindfulness like it doesn't matter
plug in whatever disease you want that's
the advice so why bother going to get
screened for that exercising just 30
minutes a day five days a week for about
an hour three times a week whatever
works for you as long as you're able to
put in those two and a half hours of
exercise per week it has to be moderate
intensity exercise
if you know you know is this moderate
intensity exercise no whammy's no
whammies no whammy's no way so the fact
that the blood pressure is being checked
while he's talking is actually wrong you
have to be seated for at least 10
minutes feet touching the ground their
feet are dangling you have to be in a
comfortable position not have recently
smoked not have recently drained
caffeine not be talking have your arms
completely at rest and ideally you want
to do it on an automated cuff and leave
the room so the cough can get the
measurement without a person in the room
because otherwise you're going to get
falsely elevated readings your blood
pressure is really nice and low it's 112
over 70. what does your heart rate
usually run do you know i have no idea
okay well you're at 87. is that good
it's normal we know that we can get your
heart rate lower when people do vigorous
exercise the best way to lower one tar
rate and it's actually the training that
i'm going through right now for boxing
is through high intensity interval
training i've heard the people that i
work with call it almost like
bodybuilding for the heart as a doctor i
don't quite like that statement because
an enlarged heart is actually a bad
heart but you want a stronger heart in
that it doesn't need to pump as often
which allows it to calm down relax
better improve filling time all of that
and we've seen better survival rates
through heart attacks less heart attacks
when you have a lower resting heart rate
usually that comes from exercise you can
also also have a low resting heart rate
very low that is pathologic meaning it's
not because you exercise well and you
actually have a problem that's why we
have the term bradycardia forward
because tom brady is really slow
and brady very upset
people who sleep less than seven hours a
night actually have a shorter life
expectancy resistance seven hours but
they're also awake more they're living
life
more
than the sleepers
i'm pretty sure that's not the case
because when we look at scientific
evidence and we look at uh we used to do
years lost so if like x number of people
died and we know that they're age 40 we
say that their average life expectancy
is 77 so we do 27 years of life loss per
person and a thousand people died we say
27 000 years lost in this case if you
die 10 years prematurely how many hours
is that
10 years
times 365 times 24. i can't do that math
but it's a huge number i can't imagine
you're saving that much more by getting
one hour extra activity and not sleeping
when people aren't sleeping it starts to
affect their heart health you might feel
invincible now and it changes on a dime
and not only does it affect your heart
it also affects your brain i feel like
as we come to terms with the sleep
deprivation that we currently face in
our society we'll come to terms with the
idea that
alzheimer's and all of these
neurological disorders that are on the
rise can be potentially fueled by the
lack of sleep that our society is
getting often we think about aging with
physical health only how much does
mental health actually affect
how long you'll live it's huge yeah it
can end up increasing our risk of heart
disease it increases our risk of things
like diabetes i have a newborn baby so
sometimes it's hard to find time for
myself when we're talking about someone
not sleeping enough when we're talking
about chronic sleep deprivation we're
really talking about a lifestyle if your
baby for the first two three weeks is
not sleeping great and causing you to
wake up early that's not going to have a
drastic impact on your entire lifespan
but if that becomes your normal habit
that even when your child is one two
three four five six years of age that's
when it becomes a problem it's a chronic
issue there is a healthy level of stress
that you can have where it's like i'm a
little stressed about this test it helps
me perform if you make stress your
friend if you view it in a positive
light like the doctor just said that you
view it as a preparation for a challenge
and something that just comes with life
that you have to manage versus all
stress is bad you actually get better
outcomes even when you have more stress
let's talk about sexual health sure what
do you want to know
if you have a preference for male or
female partner wasn't this supposed to
be about how long they're going to live
is this still the same video yes or both
the number of sexual partners you've had
in the past week or the past month i
also ask my patients what body parts
they have sex with the anus is it the
penis is it your mouth like which body
parts do you use for sex
[Music]
go ahead
go ahead zach
a lot of people don't feel comfortable
talking to their pcps about their sexual
especially in a group of their friends
around them so i understand that
i'm comfortable with it but the person
who i'm seeing is probably less
comfortable with it yeah and also um
when i have younger patients teens and
such and their parents are in the room
actually ask the parent to step out when
i have that conversation is there
anything that you're worried about or
anything that you anticipate with your
labs no but also everything the one i'm
always terrified of is the std testing
what if we have one of them we can treat
you we'll make a very interesting video
even though i have no reason to believe
that i'm positive for any i know for the
video they're probably going to order a
broad set of labs but i want you to know
at home that not everything needs to be
checked on your labs i have many
patients that come in that say doctor i
want to be checked i want to make sure i
don't have this i don't have cancer i
don't know how that it's impossible i
can never give you 100 assurance that
you're not going to have a heart attack
when you walk outside my office that
you're not going to develop a cancer the
next day it just there exists no such
tests conditions that you already have
your age your risk factors those are the
things that need to be taken into
consideration when deciding what blood
tests to order lay it on me what's the
good or bad news your blood sugar level
we want that level to be under 100 and
yours was 81 which is great and yours
was 77. yours was 117. which is totally
normal for having eaten okay i was about
to say i wonder if these are fasting
ideally we want the number to be under
100. if it's between 100 125 that's the
pre-diabetic range over 125 that is the
diabetic range now once you have
diabetes technically there is no cure
pre-diabetes you can reverse so we
encourage those people to work really
hard to reduce that let's get to the sti
testing the sexually transmitted
infection testing and you don't have
chlamydia gonorrhea hiv or syphilis so
those all came back negative that's
great news which one of us do you think
will live the longest here's why i can't
know that is because i don't know when
you guys walk out of this door what
lifestyle changes you're gonna make or
because you're not a psychic
unanswerable let's say we make no
changes based on a lot of sleeping
habits and eating habits and exercising
and mental health and wellness
i'm going to have to point to ned
which one of the three of us needs to
make the life changes the most
well
i would say
all three of you
so we're all gonna die together
did you know that i turned down a
multi-million dollar tv deal click here
for that story it's very interesting
tells you all about how the media
process works and how truly truly evil
and corrupted businesses click here to
check that out as always stay happy and
healthy